last month marvel fans got excited at
the news that tatyana meslani
was apparently the pick to play she-hulk
in a new disney plus series
of course tatyana has a huge fan base
from her emmy-winning role
on orphan black so marvel seemed like a
perfect fit for her
yeah well tatiana now says not so fast
in an interview with the sudbury star
yesterday
what's up sudbury tatiana said that
actually
isn't a real thing and it's like a press
release that's gotten out of hand it's
totally not
i've been connected to these things in
the past and press has gotten on to it
but it's
not actually a thing unfortunately
yeah now we asked disney about this this
morning and their official word
is no comment so what
what is happening here because this is
pretty rare like i mean when you hear
that you know someone's in talk
someone's you know like it's gonna
happen like this is deadline that
reported deadline is very very
you know legit source of information so
yeah do you think there's something
going on behind the scenes like is this
negotiating because she hasn't signed a
contract yet is this her
negotiating it seems strange to me
it does and the fact that mark ruffalo
tweeted about it when we found
everyone was talking about it uh it was
a big thing and there was no shutdown of
it it didn't sound like it was some kind
of
uh rumor it was actually happening
that's and the fact that disney said no
comment
there's something going on and so i
don't maybe
i think you're on the i think you're
right i think maybe this has to do with
negotiations if it's actually going to
happen
um but i hope it is like she said it's
unfortunately but
we don't know for sure maybe in a year
it will happen but
the fact that she shut it down and said
that it's unfortunate i don't know i
i hope she's not right even if it
doesn't sound
yeah yeah yeah says oh i love tatiana
she's so talented yeah she really is
siren says she-hulk lola didn't even
know there was a female version of that
what would that even look like but yeah
it's basically a green female it's all
like uh pumped up
she says when you hear someone as he
talks their deadline i sent a press
release to get an act of the part
we know how this game works hello uh
thompson says she-hulk sounds
uh silly but yeah i know something's
going on here sorry i don't know after
you go ahead
yeah no just gonna say the other reason
we were really excited about the fact
that
she-hulk was that she was going to be
intelligent that sure she was able to
have that still right so that was one of
the things that we're really excited
about so
it is interesting and again she told uh
sudbury
uh about sudbury news about this so uh
you know it wasn't a big outlet and so
the fact is we don't know what's going
to happen but we'll keep you updated if
she is going to be she-hulk i hope she
is
and i i'm sure mark ruffalo's
disappointed as well
but it's funny if like if this was a
total rumor and it got that much
attention
like now is disney like oh i guess we
have to cast tatiana maslany as
she-hulk because everyone's really
excited about it